I thought we would take one second to
check in with Andy Richter that's you
and see what stories you're working on
for the rest of the week some big news
stories and oh geez I gotta get over
there yeah get over there there we go
[Applause]
okay here's Andy Richter Andy thanks
Conan coming up this week disturbing
evidence that God is planning to shut
down and reboot the entire universe and
counterfeit prostate exams how not to
fall for them and we'll check in with
the latest bad photobombing mug shots
plus i'll bring you the story of what
one man did when life handed him lemons
and do you know which elevator button is
the germiest the answer might surprise
you we'll meet a man who won the lottery
but didn't quit his day job and meet a
scientist in Arizona who thinks he's
found the Earth's butthole the world
this is the rectum right here and our
little people being rounded up captured
in nets and put into the back of vans or
was this just an expensive reenactment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]